When observing the
natural world, many of us
notice a somewhat
beautiful dichotomy.
No two things are
ever exactly alike,
but they all seem to follow
some underlying form.
And Plato believed that the
true forms of the universe
were hidden from us.
Through observation
of the natural world,
we could merely acquire
approximate knowledge of them.
They were hidden blueprints.
The pure forms were
only accessible
through abstract reasoning of
philosophy and mathematics.
For example, the circle.
He describes as that
which has the distance
from its circumference to
its center everywhere equal.
Yet we will never find
a material manifestation
of a perfect circle, or a
perfectly straight line.
Though interestingly,
Plato speculated
that after an uncountable
number of years,
the universe will
reach an ideal state,
returning to its perfect form.
This platonic focus on
an abstract pure forms
remained popular for centuries.
And it wasn't until
the 16th century,
when people tried to
embrace the messy variation
in the real world, and apply
mathematics to tease out
underlying patterns.
Bernoulli refined the
idea of expectation.
He was focused on a method
of accurately estimating
the unknown probability
of some event,
based on the number of
times the event occurs
in independent trials.
And he uses a simple example.
Suppose that without
your knowledge
3,000 light pebbles
and 2,000 dark pebbles
are hidden in an urn.
And that, to determine the
ratio of white versus black
by experiment, you
draw one pebble
after another, with replacement,
and note how many times
a white pebble is
drawn versus black.
He went on to prove that
the expected value of white
versus black observations will
converge on the actual ratio,
as the number of
trials increases.
Known as the Weak
Law of Large Numbers.
And he concluded by saying,
if observations of all events
be continued for
the entire infinity,
it will be noticed that
everything in the world
is governed by precise ratios
and a constant law of change.
This idea was quickly
extended, as it
was noticed that
not only did things
converge on an expected
average, but the probability
of variation away
from averages also
follow a familiar underlying
shape, or distribution.
A great example of this is
Francis Galton's bean machine.
Imagine each collision as
a single independent event,
such as a coin flip.
And after 10
collisions, or events,
the bean falls into a
bucket, representing
the ratio of left
versus right deflection.
Or heads versus tails.
And this overall
curvature, known
as a binomial
distribution, appears
to be an ideal form, as it
kept appearing everywhere,
any time you looked
at the variation
of a large number
of random trials.
It seems the average
fate of these events
is somehow predetermined,
known today
as the Central Limit Theorem.
But this was a dangerous
philosophical idea to some.
And Pavel Nekrasov, originally
a theologian by training,
later took up mathematics,
and was a strong proponent
of the religious
doctrine of free will.
He didn't like the idea of
us having this predetermined
statistical fate.
And he made a famous
claim, that independence
is a necessary condition for
the law of large numbers.
Since independence just
describes these toy examples
using beans or dice, where
the outcome of previous events
doesn't change the probability
of the current or future
events.
However, as we all can
relate, most things
in the physical
world are clearly
dependent on prior outcomes.
Such as the chance of
fire, or sun, or even
our life expectancy.
And when the probability
of some event
depends, or is conditional
on previous events,
we say they are dependent
events, or dependent variables.
So this claim angered another
Russian mathematician,
Andre Markov, who maintained
a very public animosity
towards Nekrasov.
He goes on to say in a letter
that, this circumstance prompts
me to explain, in a
series of articles,
that the law of
large numbers can
apply to dependent variables.
Using a construction,
which he brags,
Nekrasov could not
even dream about.
So Markov extends Bernoulli's
results to dependent variables,
using an ingenious construction.
Imagine a coin flip, which
isn't independent, but dependent
on the previous outcome.
So it has a short term
memory of one event.
And this can be visualized using
a hypothetical machine, which
contains two cups,
which we call states.
In one state, we have a 50/50
mix of light versus dark beads.
While in the other state, we
have more dark versus light.
Now one cup we can
call state zero.
It represents a dark
having previously occurred.
And the other state,
we can call one,
it represents a light bead
having previously occurred.
Now to run our machine, we
simply start in a random state,
and make a selection.
And then we move to
either state zero or one,
depending on that event.
And based on the outcome
of that selection,
we output either a zero, if it's
dark, or a one, if it's light.
And with this
two-state machine, we
can identify four
possible transitions.
If we are in state zero,
and a black occurs,
we loop back to the same
state and select again.
If a light bead is
selected, we jump over
to state one, which can
also loop back on itself,
or jump back to state
zero, if a dark is chosen.
The probability of a light
versus dark selection
is clearly not
independent here, since it
depends on the previous outcome.
But Markov proved that as long
as every state in the machine
is reachable, when you run
these machines in a sequence,
they reach equilibrium.
That is, no matter
where you start,
once you begin the
sequence, the number
of times you visit
each state converges
to some specific
ratio or probability.
Now this simple example
disproved Nekrasov's claim
that only independent
events could
converge on predictable
distributions.
But the concept of
modeling sequences
of random events using states,
and transitions between states,
became known as a Markov chain.
And one of the first, and
most famous applications
of Markov chains, was
published by Claude Shannon.